Guys, focus class beginning. Seven eyes.
All right. Why seven? And what are they?
Zechariah 4:10. For who has despised the
day of small things? But these seven
will be glad when they see the plum line
in the hand of Zerubabel. Plum line to
measure out the temple because God had
appointed Zerubabel Joshua to rebuild
the temple. When the Jews returned from
Babylon, that's the context. The Jews
have returned from Amlon. They want to
rebuild the temple.
So the seven will be happy when they see
the plum line, the measuring line and
the Zerubabel's hand preparing to
rebuild the temple. What are the seven?
Okay, these are the seven these are the
eyes of Yahweh which roam to and fro
throughout the earth. Now did you catch
it? Glass has begun. Do you see the
seven eyes are the seven
eyes of Yahweh?
meaning
Yahweh's eyes by which he observes and
sees all things. His eyes that roam
through out the earth, meaning he's
aware of everything that's takes place.
Okay, we got it.
Please pay attention. Class is
beginning. Thank the Holy Spirit for
using me. Pray I am a doer of his word.
Mario, God bless you. Okay. Notice they
are the eyes of Yahweh, not a creature.
Jehovah Witness Unitarian
eyes of Yahweh which roam to and fro
throughout the earth and they are seven
I'll show you why seven in a minute
something I've discussed but creature
repetition
on this one stone are seven eyes
and that
refers to the seven eyes of Yahweh we
got it right seven eyes on a stone seven
eyes of Yahweh these are Yahweh's eyes
by which he's aware of what takes place
throughout the earth. Nothing escapes
his sight. Not a creature. Now, John
knows his Old Testament. Now, look what
John did. John knows his Old Testament.
Then I saw in the midst of the throne
and the four living creatures, in the
midst of the others, a lamb standing,
I'm going to break down the imagery, as
if slain, having seven horns and seven
eyes, which are the seven spirits of God
sent out into all the earth.
What is John doing by ascribing to Jesus
the very eyes
of Yahweh?
And he says those seven eyes of Yahweh
are the seven eyes of Jesus. And those
seven eyes are the seven spirits of God.
Did you see what he did?
Everyone got it? Let's see if you got
it. John knows the Old Testament and he
took a reference to the eyes of Yahweh
and he ascribed it to the lamb. The
lamb. Why does Jesus the lamb have the
eyes of Yahweh?
If he's a creature, he's not Yahweh.
Because Zechariah 3:9 and 4:10 says,
"The seven eyes are the seven eyes of
Yahweh that roam to and fro the earth."
But John says, "The seven eyes are the
seven eyes of the lamb Jesus Christ,
which are the seven spirits sent out
into all the earth."
Everyone got it? But now, let me explain
again once again the seven spirits and
seven eyes and seven horns. Why seven?
I've done it before. We'll do it again.
Okay. Seven becomes a number for
perfection and completion. How do we
know? All right. Now, let's go through
this.
Okay, here's why. Seven became known as
the number of perfection. Why?
Genesis 131. And God saw all that had
made. And behold, it was very good. And
there was evening, there was morning,
the sixth day. So God completed the
creation in six days. Everything was
complete, finished, and very good.
Therefore, he stopped working on the
seventh day. Genesis 2:es 1-3. Okay.
Genesis 2:es
1-3.
Yep. Blessed the heavens and earth were
complete and all their hosts. And on the
seventh day, God completed his work. So
seven becomes a number of completion.
His work is complete.
Doesn't need to add anything. He now
needs to maintain and sustain and
preserve. So seven becomes a number of
completion.
which he had done and he rested on
Sunday from all his work which he had
done. Then God blessed the seventh day
and sanctified it because on it he
rested from all his work which God had
created and making it. So seven becomes
a number of completion complete. If
something is complete, it's perfect. If
it's perfect, it lacks nothing.
And here James 1:4, if you're complete,
you're perfect, lacking nothing. And let
perseverance have its perfect work so
that you may be perfect and complete
lacking in nothing. Are we making the
connection?
Connection clear?
Yep. Is he? Just pay attention. You'll
follow me. So why did he stop working on
the seventh day? Here's why. Because God
completed his work. If it's complete, it
lacks nothing. Therefore, perfect. So
seven now becomes a number for
completion, perfection. We got it.
You watch here though. We're going to go
a little deeper.
Okay.
So now Revelation 15:1, how many plagues
does it take for God's wrath to be fully
spent, poured out, completed? Seven.
Then I saw another sign in heaven, great
and marvelous, seven angels who have
seven plagues, which are the last
because in them the wrath of God is
finished. It takes seven plagues to
complete God's wrath where God's wrath
is fully spent.
So again, seven completion, his wrath is
now fully poured out. We got it now. So
I can move on now to the point.
Let me know, guys, because I'm gonna go
slowly,
right?
You got it here.
I know there's a 16-second delay, but I
got to wait because I'm not going fast.
I'm going slow for you guys. All right.
So, now let's break down the
implication.
Seven eyes means that Jesus has perfect
sight. He perfectly sees. He perfectly
observes. He's fully aware. Nothing
escapes his grasp. He's aware of
everything everyone does on earth. No
one is hidden from him. Nothing escapes
his grasp because he has perfect sight
and sees everything perfectly. But now
notice though, the seven eyes are the
seven spirits because this is a
reference to the Holy Spirit. Why is the
spirit of God said to be seven? Not
because there are seven spirits. This is
unlike the seven angels here. It's about
the spirit, not angels. Because this is
referring to the Holy Spirit in his
perfection. The Holy Spirit is perfect.
All his works are perfect. That's why
seven spirits denoting the perfection of
the Holy Spirit. He's perfect and all he
does, everything he does is perfect. But
I don't know if you see the connection.
No. Uh, seven spirits are not the seven
angels. When John wants you to know
about the seven angels, he'll say seven
angels. All right. Now, you see it. But
what's the connection though? Notice the
lamb and Jesus are inseparable.
What this means is that Jesus in union
with the Holy Spirit
by
the Holy Spirit in union with the Holy
Spirit is fully aware of all things. So
this shows you not only is Christ fully
aware of everything, the Holy Spirit is
also fully aware and he's omnipresent
because the Holy Spirit
fills the earth
and the Holy Spirit filling the earth is
still
united to Christ in heaven. meaning the
spirit is on earth and he's in heaven
because the lamb is in heaven and the
seven eyes are the seven spirits that
are on the face of the lamb. So the
spirit is in heaven and earth filling
heaven and earth. And because of Christ
inseparable union the spirit where the
spirit is Christ is where Christ is the
spirit is because the spirit comes to
give us access to the father and son
unite us to the father and son and make
the father son present to us.
Focus mati please.
Do you see it? Now you're now seeing the
deity of the son and the spirit and what
we call the inseparable operations of
the trinity. Paracoresis, the technical
term, the father works, the son works,
the spirit works. They all work
together. The father is in the son and
the spirit. The son's in the spirit and
in the father and spirit is in the
father son.
Okay, I'm going to break down seven
horns. Okay, watch here. So here the
Holy Spirit appears visibly. So when
people say, "Will we see the Holy
Spirit?" Yes. Here John is seeing the
Holy Spirit as seven eyes
even though the spirit isn't literally
an eye.
Okay? Now, let me show you something
else. Pay attention. What are the seven
horns?
Learn this, please. I've discussed this
millions of times, but increase the
repetition because I'm going explain to
you the lamb. Why is he appearing as a
lamb? No matter what you do, what is a
horn?
And the 10 horns
which you saw are 10 kings. A horn is a
king
who have not yet received the kingdom,
but they receive authority as kings with
the beast for one hour. So a horn is a
king who has a kingdom who has power,
sovereignty, dominion.
Now if that's the case, what does it
mean for Christ to have seven horns?
It means he's the almighty king.
He's the all powerful king. Seven horns.
Horn is a king with power, dominion,
sovereignty. Meaning Jesus's sovereignty
is perfect. His dominion is perfect.
He's almighty, all powerful. Because
he's the almighty king, no king can even
dare to come up against him. No king can
rival him. He's a sovereign, almighty,
all powerful king. Showing you that
Jesus is omnipotent.
Meaning his power, his dominion is
perfect. His sovereignty is perfect.
Lacks nothing. That means he's almighty.
So here you see Jesus is almighty, all
knowing and the spirit is all knowing
and present everywhere
capish.
We got it.
We got it. That's why he's able to
conquer, destroy all kingdoms, all
armies, because his power is unrivaled.
He's almighty, sovereign over all kings.
That's why he can subjugate them. So
here you have revelation five. The son
is not the spirit. The son is not God
the father. But the son and the spirit
the father are the almighty god. Do we
got it now or no?
Because now the spirit appears in two
different forms. Here John sees the
spirit as seven eyes. But in the same
vision, same vision, look what he sees
him as. Four, five,
same vision.
And out from the throne, throne of God
come flashes of lightning and sounds and
peels of thunder. And there were seven
lamps of fire burning before the throne,
which are the seven spirits of God. Do
you see how God almighty can assume
various shapes, multiple shapes
at the same time? He can appear in
multiple forms simultaneously. So here
John sees the seven spirits of seven
lamps before the throne. But in the same
vision he then sees the same seven
spirits as seven eyes. Revelation 5:6 on
the face of the lamb.
You got it.
You got it?
That answers the question. Can the
father be seen, the son be seen, spirit?
Yes. Will we see all of them? Yes,
you will.
You got it.
All right. But now, why is he appearing
as lamps? Well, you use a lamp to
lighten your path. They didn't have
electricity back then. So they will
light lamps to find their way in the
dark. So what it means is
perfect illumination.
That light that you need to see and
understand the way of salvation to find
yourself out of darkness comes from the
throne of God. And that perfect
illumination that comes from the throne
of God is the Holy Spirit. Meaning the
Holy Spirit is the one who grants us
perfect illumination because he's
perfect. His enlightenment is perfect.
So he gives us perfect enlightenment.
That's what it means. Here's your
trinity. Here is your perfect deity. The
Holy Spirit is perfect. He gives you
perfect illumination. He perfectly sees
and he's perfectly aware and he's
omnipresent. The lamb is almighty king
and he perfectly sees and he's perfectly
aware. And yet the lamb is not the
spirit. Spirit's not the lamb and the
lamb spirit are not God the father and
the throne. There's your trinity.
Why then does he appear as a lamb?
Now let's break that down. Lamb. Notice
a lamb slain but he's alive. Let's see
why a lamb standing as of slain. Now
notice that means the imagery is he sees
a lamb with the throat slit.
A lamb with the throat slit. Okay,
please pay attention. He sees a lamb
with the throat slit, but it's alive.
You know why? Cuz Christ has been
resurrected,
right? Jesus was slain, but he was
raised immortal. So he sees the slit
throat of the lamb, but the lamb is
alive because he conquered death.
and he's now raised immortal. Okay,
that's the imagery. But why a lamb? Why
a male lamb? Let me explain it now. Let
me show you what the word for lamb is.
We ready to go into this? Here you go.
Revelation 5:6.
Here you go. The lamb.
Aron. Aron. Let's see what it is. Here
it is.
Okay. Let's look at it.
Okay. Arnneon, a lamb. Notice what it
is. A little lamb.
A lamb. It refers to a young male lamb
with me there. Do you see it? Young male
lamb. Young.
It's not just the word lamb. It's young
lamb. A young male lamb. Because Jesus
is a male, right? You see it?
Why?
Why a young male lamb
aron a sheep properly? A young lamb. A
little lamb. A person with puress and
virginike gentle intentions. You caught
it or no? You know why? A little lamb. A
lamb.
Anyone get an idea?
Let's see if you know. Remember I said
John is full of references to the Old
Testament.
Testament,
right? Are you listening? Holy Spirit,
help us to focus.
Yes. Because he's the Passover lamb.
Bam.
What John is telling you is that Jesus
is our Passover lamb. In other words, if
you guys are listening, do you know what
the story of the New Testament is?
If you read Exodus 12, God told the
Israelites to find a one-year-old
male lamb, a one-year-old male lamb,
slaughter it, eat the flesh, don't broke
its bones, take the blood, mix it in
with bitter herbs and hissup, put that
on the top and the side of the doors,
and then death will pass over that
house. And it was the slaying of the
Passover lamb resulting in the death of
the firstborn of the Egyptians that
resulted in Israel being set free from
their captivity and bondage to slavery.
With me there?
If you don't study the Bible, you're not
going to understand. The New Testament
is a story of a new exodus,
of a new Israel, being taken out of a
new Egypt, being set free from their
bondage, their slavery to a new Pharaoh,
going through a new wilderness as they
make their way to a new Canaan, heavenly
Jerusalem. That's the story of the
Bible.
That's why if you pay attention to the
plagues in Revelation, they're the same
plagues that God brought down on the
Egyptians.
He saved you from bondage to sin and
Satan.